[موسيقى]
ما أحبه حقًا
في التواجد في الغابة هو رؤية
حجم التغيير الذي يمكننا فعله حقًا هو أنه من
الممكن
حقًا إعادة تلك الغابة
[موسيقى]
كرّس لوري كولين حياته
لاستعادة غابة الأطلسي في البرازيل
بعد  عند مشاهدة تدمير
مسقط رأسه
، اعتادت مجموعة غابات ساو باولو الأطلسية الغربية
أن تكون ذات
مناظر طبيعية جميلة ومتواصلة خضراء ، ما كان يمثل
مائة بالمائة من الغطاء الحرجي الآن
هو فقط
عقدين من إزالة الغابات أدى إلى
انخفاض كبير بمقدار واحد
من أكثر الموائل تنوعًا في العالم ،
كل ما تبقى من الغابة عبارة
عن شظايا معزولة ،
وهذا يعني أن العديد من الأنواع مهددة الآن
لأنها لم تعد
لديها القدرة على تشتيت الحياة البرية
خاصةً أنك تعلم أن جاكوار بوما
أوسلوتس معزولة جدًا
في بقع غابات صغيرة
لا يمكنها ذلك  نرى بعضنا
البعض عندما نبدأ في مواجهة مشاكل
اكتئاب الأقارب
الذي يمكن أن يقتل السكان المحليين في
وقت قصير  يستخدم مصطلح
كولين وفريقه نهجًا مستهدفًا
لاستعادة الغابات
مع أخذ ما تبقى من الأجزاء
والزرع في
الممرات ، وتهدف هذه الممرات المقترحة إلى
ربط الأجزاء
والعمل تقريبًا كطريق سريع سريع
للأنواع المحلية
يضع تطبيق الحلم الأولويات
أو حيث  يجب أن تكون الغابة
حقًا للتأكد من أننا وضعنا الممرات الصحيحة
في الأماكن الصحيحة
حتى الآن ، استعاد فريقه وفريقه
3000 هكتار من
الغابات وأخبرنا أنهم رأوا بالفعل
ما لا يقل عن نصف الأنواع المحلية التي تستخدمها
بما في ذلك بعض الحيوانات الأكثر تعرضًا للخطر  من
الانقراض
اليوم ، من الممكن بالفعل
رؤية أسد التمر الهندي وعائلات
هذا القرد الصغير
بمفردهم باستخدام بعض الأحياء في الغابة
التي أعدناها إذا واصلنا
استمرار بقاء هذه الأنواع المهددة بالانقراض
على ما يرام على المدى الطويل
يحفز مصطلح cullen كل من
الفوائد المجتمعية والمناخية
لإعادة التحريج ،
لكن إنجازاته تمثل
تحولًا  هذا أمر
شخصي بقدر ما هو عمل خيري ،
اعتدت أن أكون صيادًا كما تعلم أن والدي
كان يصطحبني للصيد
في أمازون ، لذا فقد تواصلت
مع الغابات التي قتلت الكثير من الأنواع المهددة بالانقراض ،
لكنني الآن
أقوم بدوري  لإعادة كل هذه الغابة
مرة أخرى في
محاولة لاسترداد كل السمعة السيئة
التي كانت لدي في الماضي ،
فإن جهود [الموسيقى] كولين لا تفيد فقط
المناظر الطبيعية
ولكن أيضًا المجتمعات التي تعيش عليها ، فإن
الأشخاص هم حقًا جزء من
معادلة
الاستعادة التي نقوم بها  قام به
السكان
المحليون وفريقه وضعوا
لأنفسهم هدفًا طموحًا يتمثل
في إعادة ممرات تغطي
ستين ألف هكتار من الأرض
تعادل عشرين بالمائة من المنطقة بأكملها.
لدينا رؤية لدينا مهمة لدينا
خريطة وهذا كل ما لدينا  لن نستسلم
ولدينا الكثير لنفعله